welcome back i thought i'd do a couple
of uh centripetal acceleration problems
some of the more common ones that you're
you maybe see in school so let's say i
have a well it could be a hot wheel or
it could be a car a real car and let's
say it's on a track so let me draw the
track
oh it's a good color for a track i don't
know yellow it's a yellow track so this
is going to be a side view
and we all remember this from our hot
wheel days and the track does a
loop-de-loop
like that
and then i have a car and let's say it's
going at a constant velocity we're not
going to worry about the cars
or at least a constant speed right
because the direction of the velocity
might change just not the magnitude so
this is the car
and my question to you is how fast does
it have to be going what's what's its
speed have to be for it to not fall when
it gets to this point in the loopty loop
so it's going to go like this this is
going to be the path of the car
how fast does it need to go
so let's just think about it oh of
course i have to give a little bit of
information let's say the radius of this
loop-de-loop
let's say the radius of this
is
i don't know let's say it's 20 feet i'm
making this up on the fly i hope the
numbers work out well
so at
what we have to figure out is
essentially what is this interpretable
acceleration going to be on this car and
if we know the centripetal acceleration
we know the radius we can figure out the
velocity
so let's just think about what happens
to the car as it goes up the loop to
loop at this point let's say when the
car is right here so this is the car
what is making the car's velocity change
right because you know at this point the
car's velocity is like this and then at
this point the car's velocity is like
this at this point the car's velocity is
like this it's always going to be
tangent to the loop-de-loop
well at this point down here it's
actually going to be the normal force of
the loop-de-loop right as the car is
kind of driving into the slope
the slope is putting upward pressure on
the car that's making it go in the
circular path
but as we go
beyond this point we see something
interesting happening there's going to
be the normal force
of the
of the um
of the loop-de-loop itself of the
surface and then we're also going to
start having gravity pulling down on the
car and some portion of the gravity will
kind of pull to the center and it's a
little complicated at this point
but at this point let me draw the car
at this point let me draw the upside
down car
what are the forces
well
if we want the car to just not fall
right we'll have to that the only force
is going to be the force of gravity or
the acceleration of gravity
if the car is going fast enough to
offset the acceleration of gravity
then it'll stay on the loop-de-loop
so let's figure out how fast it has to
be going to offset the acceleration of
gravity
well we know from the previous video
that the centripetal acceleration
is equal to
the magnitude i'm going to put an
absolute value around that so you know
it's not the velocity vector it's the
magnitude of the of the velocity i know
i keep changing conventions but that's
good for you because you'll see
different things divided by the radius
velocity squared over radius remember
this isn't the vector this is just the
magnitude
and once again this is also just the
magnitude of the acceleration vector so
we know what the acceleration vector is
at this point it's
it's minus 32 well we just want to we
we're just worried about the magnitude
so we'll say it's 32 feet per second
squared that's the acceleration of
gravity on the surface of the earth at
sea level 30 feet per second squared and
that equals
the velocity squared i'll get rid of the
absolute value sign
or the magnitude sign divided by the
radius divided by 20.
and so multiply both sides by 20 i get
is equal to
velocity
squared
and so 64
square root
whoops
640 square root is 25.3
so the car has to be going 25.3
feet per second
so now ask your question what happens if
it's going at 20 feet per second well if
it's going 20 feet per second someplace
around here let me draw the path of the
slow of a slower car going 20 feet per
second if the car's going 20 feet per
second it'll probably make it pretty far
and then someplace around here it's just
going to start falling and then it'll
fall down
that's the car going 20 feet per second
i'll do that in 20 feet per second
now just another question what's going
to happen if the car goes
faster let's say let's what happens if
the velocity is and i'll do it in a
different color
what happens if the velocity is i don't
know 50 feet per second so this is a
super fast car
well at this point
so so if if this was just a simple orbit
problem what would happen we have this
centripetal acceleration from gravity
but that alone isn't enough to offset
its velocity so if we have no other
forces other than gravity the car would
kind of
exit its orbit you could kind of say
right it would actually go out of its
path it might it might do something like
this whoops its path might look
something like this i know i draw these
very messy things but it might actually
fly out right
so what's keeping it from flying out
well the actual surface of the
loop-de-loop
right so we have something very
interesting going on here if a car is
going really fast well let's figure it
out what does the centripetal
acceleration have to be well if the car
is going 50 feet per second in order to
keep it going in a circle
the acceleration has to be
50 squared
over the radius which is 20.
50 times 50. so that's
with two zeros over 20.
when the zeros cancel so the
acceleration is going to have to be 125
feet per second
the inward acceleration the centripetal
acceleration has to be 125 feet per
second
so what's going on gravity is only going
to provide 32 feet per second of that so
the rest of it is actually going to be
the normal force of the surface
of the loop-de-loop or of the surface of
the road because the car is going to
push the car is going to want to do
the car is going to want to kind of exit
its orbit it's going to want to do
something like that and what's keeping
it from doing that is the road the road
is keeping the car contained and so it's
essentially putting enough extra force
uh enough extra normal force onto the
car and and so that force will kind of
you know it'll be applied to the tires
to offset that and that and and there
you have it and and so it'll if so think
of it this way if you were if you were
tied if there was a if you were tied to
the
to the loop to loop on the inside right
here
you know if this is some kind of western
movie where the heroine is about to die
and there's a car coming that's that's
going to roll her over
if that car is going at exactly 20 25.3
feet per second
to the it'll probably just kind of bump
over the heroin actually the heroin will
probably cause the car to fall and she
probably won't die
but if that car is going at 50 feet per
second
then there's enough normal force so you
know the the the the road is pushing
on the car and of course isn't equal in
opposite force so the car is pushing
down and that amount that the car is
pushing down would would squish the
heroin
so i don't know if that was disturbing
or useful or confusing but just another
way to think about things anyway i'll
see in the next video